احتلت صوره اردوغان بقوائم الاقتراع هذه
سنوات من عمر الانتخابات في البلاد فمنذ
عقدين والرئيس رئيس او مرشح فهذا الرجل
الذي اكل الشيب والسياسه راسه ما زال صوته
يسعفه في ان يخطب بجماهيره الغفيره اذ وظف
الموارد الحكوميه لصالحه وانفق بس خائن
على البنيه التحتيه لارضاء الناخبين
كل هذه الاكياس التي كانت تجهز لتحسي ما
نتائج الانتخابات التركيه تتكدس فيها
اصوات الاتراك والتي اثبتت ان للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حصه الاسد فيها
امام منافسه المعارض لا تشدار اوغلو حتى
الان على الرغم من ان هذه الاسواق التركيه
تعج بالمنتجات الا ان الوضع الاقتصادي
المتردي يسمح لعدد كبير من الاتراك
بالمشاهده فقط لا بالشراء اذ يرغ الان
بحسب مراقبين ببعض الاستقرار ويستبعدون
فكره التغيير فالبلاد لم تعد تحتمل اي نوع
من المجازفات خاصه وان الرئيس التركي يلعب
على حبال سياسيه عده قضيه اللاجئين
السوريين والتوغل التركي في شمال الاراضي
السوريه فكل هؤلاء المقاتلين يتدربون
منتظرين اشاره واحده من انقره نحو هدف
مقبل اضافه الى ان اردوغان قام بسلسله
هجمات عسكريه استهدفت جماعات كرديه في
البلاد وخارج حدود البلاد باتجاه كل من
العراق وسوريا هجمات تباها بانها نفذت عبر
طائرات مسيره وحربيه تركيه الصنع
فالصناعات العسكريه المحليه لقيت صدى
واسعا لدى الناخبين بحسب محللين كانت هذه
السيده تبكي بحرقه قبل اشهر على قبر احد
ضحايا الزل لا شك ان وعود اردوغان باعاده
الاعمار لن تبرد من حرقه قلبها كثيرا
فزلزال فبراير جعل بلادا تهتز باكملها
فيما بقي كرسي الحكم ثابتا في مكانه ينتظر
ان كان صاحبه سيعود اليه على عجل هل العلي
العربي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات